hello everyone it's bradley from some
sub here now i've been reading your
comments attentively and i think we're
ready for a new co-host so without
further ado i'm presenting my colleague
emily from the london malabone office
and she's going to give you a new video
that i hope you'll enjoy
so hello everyone my name's emily and
welcome to some sub a channel about
survival in the digital jungle to get us
started i'd like to start with a
question for you
have you taped over the webcam on your
laptop
if your answer is yes then i have two
pieces of news for you the first that is
good news is that you're not alone in
your efforts to ensure the security of
your personal life take a look at this
photo mark zuckerberg posted it in 2016.
now take a closer look at the laptop in
the left corner of the image you can see
that mark has taped over his webcam and
microphone with paper tape the facebook
founder's post made a lot of noise
for the first time many users thought
about the fact that their personal life
could become an object of interest to
intruders the trend of covering cameras
has since overwhelmed offices according
to one of the manufacturers of antivirus
programs about 40 of users have also
started doing this
17 did it using a regular plaster the
same number stuck a post-it note over
the camera and about 5
used ordinary tape edward snowden and
the fbi director james comey have
repeatedly spoken about the danger of
webcams some laptop manufacturers such
as lenovo have even added hardware
protection against peeping small plastic
blinds or privacy shutters have appeared
on their cameras but i use a different
approach
look there's no camera at all on my
laptop
[Music]
covering the lens with tape is really
just an illusion of security
most often attackers are interested in
what you're discussing with colleagues
and for this it's enough just to access
the microphone
a thin piece of tape will not prevent
them from getting a sound recording
furthermore documents on your computer
messages accounts passwords are much
more valuable targets
seller tape or plaster can't provide any
protection against this besides i don't
really like integrated webcams the
quality of the image they produce
resembles the first mobile phone cameras
and the camera on the laptop screen
doesn't really show the face from the
best angle therefore for video calls i
prefer to use an external camera which i
connect by usb if i have to use laptops
with built-in cameras i disable them at
the operating level and delete the
drivers this is so much more reliable
than a strip of paper tape now the story
about webcams gave me the idea of rating
other office spies
do you want to know which technology is
really worth being afraid of
well let's start with light bulbs
so in recent years we've been surrounded
by things with the word smart in the
name
now this really isn't that surprising an
inexpensive microchip such as the
esp8266 costs less than a dollar for
manufacturers but if you add it to any
device the price has increased several
times therefore refrigerators microwaves
air conditioners and even power tools
have acquired similar microcontrollers
therefore they've also acquired the
possibility to exchange information via
wireless networks
this is called the internet of things or
iot for short
today 46 billion different devices are
connected to the network and their
number is growing rapidly information
security experts like to repeat that the
s in iot stands for security
unfortunately this isn't a joke
your smart lamps coffee makers vacuum
cleaners are practically defenseless
against hackers
most often attackers use them to
organize botnets
now this was described in detail by
lucas in another video on our channel so
today i'm going to talk about another
threat
smart things smart devices help hackers
hack into your life for example in march
2021 hackers successfully hacked 150 000
smart security cameras at once
and these aren't just simple home
devices they've been installed in police
stations schools hospitals and offices
we've seen such cases before but this
time the attackers received a video
even from the office of the manufacturer
of these cameras a company named varcada
but if the dangers of network cameras or
baby monitors
is in principle obvious
then other smart devices are often
overlooked
in 2017 hackers broke into an online
casino database using a smart aquarium
controller
instead of feeding the fish and
monitoring the water the device helps to
get 10 gigabytes of confidential
information about the players and send
it on to a finished server but more
often hackers use a different technique
imagine that you've equipped your office
with smart lamps no matter how good they
are sooner or later the leds in them
burn out and what do you do with these
burnt out lamps
well of course you throw it away
the only problem is that wi-fi settings
are stored in their memory
attackers can find a discarded lamp
recover the data and gain full access to
your network
in addition smart devices are
practically defenseless to hacking from
the outside therefore if you want to
take advantage of the benefits of
technological progress never connect
them to a shared network of an apartment
or an office connect them to a separate
wi-fi router and monitor traffic
regularly
this way you'll protect your main
network and quickly detect any hacking
attempts i'd also advise you to never
throw away smart devices as ordinary
garbage you don't throw away pieces of
paper with passwords written on them do
you so don't be too lazy to physically
destroy the memory of a smart light bulb
or switch and it's not just smart
devices that can be responsible for
leaking your passwords
the attack can be carried out using a
charger for your smartphone
[Music]
we're always discussing the topic of
identity in our videos for example how
we can make sure who is who in the
online jungle and the technology of
self-sovereign identity can become truly
revolutionary in the topic of
identification
just imagine that all information about
you is stored on one blockchain wallet
and is completely under your control
well a video discussing exactly that was
released on our second channel where
tony the head of legal at some some of
my very good friend talked about this
technology in more detail i highly
recommend that you watch it
our smartphones are getting faster and
more intelligent every year but they
still have to be charged almost every
day the first mobile phones use
different connectors for charging and
connecting to computers
but today engineers have combined them
into one interface
this is what the attackers take
advantage of they add microchips to
charges that can be used to hack
smartphones the first time we saw this
angle of attack was in 2011 at the
defcon conference
hackers have developed compact devices
for hacking smartphones this type of
hacking is called juice jacking
in 2019 a hacker hiding behind the
nickname mg presented his development
the omg cable
it looks like a regular wire with a
lightning interface but it can be used
to hack apple computers and laptops
the device costs just 200
and allows you to seamlessly exchange
data with the victim's computer at a
distance of up to 90 meters so that's
why i never use other people's charges
or cables when traveling i always carry
my own power bank the controller in it
is too simple and it doesn't store any
personal data so there's nothing to hack
here hence i calmly charge the power
bank from any available charger and then
from this i charge my smartphone at home
and in the office i use only my device
accessories
each of them is marked in a special way
that only i know about so criminals
won't be able to replace them with
something that looks similar
now by the way i stole the idea of
marking my accessories from printer
manufacturers
did you know that color laser printers
specifically leave a unique digital
signature on paper
[Music]
each of us has a unique handwriting
graphology experts are able to determine
who wrote a letter in just a few
sentences now of course criminals have
known about this for a long time so they
used different methods to obscure their
handwriting
first they cut letters out of newspapers
and magazines and later they began to
use printing devices take a look at this
typewriter
it also has its own unique handwriting
there are tiny defects on the letters
scratches and scuffs so a criminologist
can easily determine which typewriter a
letter was written on but with the
advent of printers the police
encountered a problem it became much
more difficult to identify a good
printer compared to a fingerprint
therefore printer manufacturers have
implemented machine identification code
technology however this became famous
under a different name
yellow dots you're unlikely to be able
to see them with the naked eye
this is a photo of a piece of paper with
these dots even with a 10-fold
magnification they're almost impossible
to distinguish to spot them you'll have
to enlarge the image another six times
in fact these dots are clearly visible
if you illuminate the paper with an
ultraviolet lamp but why are they needed
well it's so that the police or security
services can determine when and on which
printer this page was printed
see the serial number of the device and
the date of printing are encrypted in
the dots
simple yet effective in 2017 the yellow
dots formed the basis of accusations
against reality winner she printed out
classified nsa materials and handed them
over to journalists from the intercept
the journalists asked the
representatives of the intelligence
agency to comment on the information
they had received
and those who received copies of the
printouts managed to establish who made
them these yellow dots cost winner five
years of life behind bars i don't want
to give any advice to potential
criminals but personally i try not to
share the originals of important
documents
as a rule it's enough just to copy them
several times on a low quality copier
this will allow you to get rid of micro
printing by the way copiers are also not
as simple as they may seem
try to make a colour copy of euros or
dollars
i bet you can't do it
[Music]
the fact is that a special image is
hidden on these bills it serves as a
signal that they cannot be copied
this code is sometimes called urian
constellation and it looks very simple
it's made up of five rings that are
located at a strictly defined distance
from each other
this pattern is hidden on euros dollars
pounds and four dozen different
banknotes
but you can use it too on your documents
if you want to protect them from copying
add the urine constellation pattern
using a special program
this will not protect them from being
photographed but for scanning or copying
it will work perfectly now let's talk
about your own digital handwriting
[Music]
did you realize that your computer's
keyboard is the perfect whistleblower
this is especially true for wireless
models
now this was most clearly demonstrated
by sami kamcart
a few years ago using the basics of
amateur electronic modules he created a
device called keysweeper it looks like a
simple power supply and is even capable
of charging smartphones via a usb cable
similar ones can be found in any office
it's just that keysweeper is actually a
spy
it listens to radio broadcasts in the
2.4 gigahertz band
many models of microsoft wireless
keyboards work at this frequency
of course they transmit data about the
keys press in encrypted form
but it turned out that this code can be
hacked using arduino
keysweeper decrypts on the fly and saves
a detailed log of all the keys pressed
the device can also share recordings
over wi-fi to the attacker's computer
and you know what's the most amazing
thing
keysweeper assembly parts will cost you
just 10
therefore
if you use wireless keyboards no matter
which manufacturer
just give them up
i recommend using simple wired models
because they're much safer
and never connect them via usb hubs it's
pretty easy to install a controller in
the hub housing that will record all
keystrokes you make and one more
important tip with really confidential
information i only work with quiet
keyboards
for example a model like this i would
completely avoid
to art it different keys of such a
keyboard sound the same
but even the microphone of your
smartphone is able to pick up the
difference between them
or at least that's what researchers from
texas say professor larson claims that
with the help of a microphone they were
able to detect the pressing of a
specific key in 41 of cases
now do you think that's a low percentage
if you don't use a random combination of
characters in your password for example
you use meaningful words or dates then
this is quite enough to hack your
account and of course a smartphone is
the enemy of privacy
turn it off when working with critical
data or better yet switch to the good
old butter models altogether you really
can't go wrong with a nokia brick phone
a modern smartphone has a unique digital
fingerprint
this unique number for working in the
cellular network is called imei
the module for working with the internet
also has a special identifier the mac
address
your phone can be identified by
bluetooth parameters browser features
installed fonts and much more logging
sessions with wi-fi access points can
tell attackers a lot about your activity
and habits and become the key to
planning an attack on your device
now we've already covered this in detail
in the video about the dangers of public
networks network equipment is constantly
in the field of view of hackers
attackers regularly find flaws in their
software and publish them as zero
zero-day vulnerabilities
whilst manufacturers are working to
eliminate them your network may be
vulnerable to being hacked
popular wi-fi equipment models are
particularly vulnerable to such attacks
so to protect yourself from these kind
of attacks work on the settings of your
network equipment
change the characteristic names ports
and management interface settings
replace the identifiers of real
equipment with analogs from other
manufacturers this will be enough to
confuse novice hackers
but wi-fi networks can also be used to
track people without smartphones
the wi-fi project allows you to
literally see through walls
engineers of defence companies have been
trying to develop systems that can scan
rooms with the help of radio waves
this kind of technology can be useful
for fighting terrorists or conducting
rescue operations
but such radars had one significant
drawback
their radiation is too noticeable via
the radio
criminals could easily spot them with
simple scanners professor dina katabi
went the other way device operates in
the same range as conventional wi-fi
routers the wireless vision system scans
through the room and all you'll notice
is a slight amplification of the wi-fi
signal now i don't believe any of our
viewers are planning crimes that will
need to put this system to work but the
very fact of its existence reminds us of
an important rule of digital hygiene
always keep a close eye on wireless
network activity a new device or even
more so a new wireless network may
indicate that your information is in
danger
wireless key loggers traffic
interception devices scanners and
similar equipment operate on public
networks
private wireless networks also face an
increased threat of hacking
do not use wireless adapters on
computers to work with classified
information
everything that is transmitted
wirelessly can potentially end up in the
hands of intruders even the traffic of
nfc devices that only work a distance of
a few centimeters can be intercepted and
used against you
[Music]
so remember this there's no such thing
as being too careful
the world of digital security is complex
and unpredictable
along with the huge opportunities
offered by modern technologies come
unforeseen threats
for comfort and convenience you have to
pay with increased risks everyone should
determine the balance between these
conveniences and risks for themselves
but let's agree that no matter how
important our secrets are we're unlikely
to return to candles and typewriters
or
am i wrong
[Music]
i want to hear your thoughts so write in
the comments down below what you're
willing to sacrifice for the sake of
digital security and what you absolutely
refuse to give up even under the threat
of complete dn anonymization so my name
is emily this has been some sub and i'll
see you in our next video
[Music]